[Musique]
tu vas être génial
je t'aime
bye
jolie souliers jolie souliers faites que
la chance puisse m'accompagner et
comment allez-vous d'ailleurs Christine
avec ce qui est arrivé
bonjour bonjour Christine excusez-moi
est-ce que je vous connais je suis venu
vous aider vous m'avez appelé
j'ai dû oublier faut le faire pour
oublier ça
ravi de vous connaître Diana
[Musique]
je m'en occupe ça va aller
c'est de la médecine traditionnelle non
on dirait que le brouillard s'est levé
ce n'est pas permanent
je suis heureuse
je serai toujours avec toi pour toujours
parfois il t'arrive de perdre le fil ou
d'être distraite il faut me faire
confiance mes médicaments ont disparu
elle voulait te contrôler
ce n'est pas moi qui ai besoin de
contrôler
sortez de la tête de ma femme si ses
problèmes sont dans sa tête je les
trouverai je les ferai partir
pourquoi elle mentirais
laissez-moi entrer je vais essayer
et vous serez libre